Hôm nay, trong tiến tụi báo của ngàn thì phố xin mình, phòng cạnh sất kinh tế, con ngàn thì phố xin mình và chỉ phá một đường dài xa chế,
tế thuệu thịt óc bường hả chứ không việc với bố đặc biệt lắm.
Chứ đó, đơn vị tinh hành kinh chà một cơ xử xe thịt phẩm không bị vự tại số sau miếng dịch các biệt lức phương biệt đồng.
Tại thương điểm kinh chà, con ngàn phát hiện và tạm sữa hôm bà tấn thịt óc bường đã qua xe chế,
tên vụ được ngâm trong dịch hóa chất nát tri xí lịch át, thương gọi là thịt tinh lắm.
Mà dụi kinh chà, lực lượng trực năng tức phát hiện,
tụi giữ thêm 1 miên năng trong 715 gà hóa chất nát tri xí lịch át được cơ xấu để vụ vụ vụ vụ ngọt.
Khi lận giám định của vình tự hòa hình sự tại thành phố xin mình xác liệt,
tất cả các bẫu thịt óc đều chữa nát tri xí lịch át, hóa chất cơ miệp dùng trong xe dự.
Sa sất đại xí mong, tệ đối không được phép sử dụng trong xe diễn thực phẩm,
đé là chức có tính kiểm mạnh có thể gây tổn thương hệ thương hả?
Ik đừng ra mắt bà tìm ở nguyên cộng đối với suy hành người thương.
Lâm việc với các quan đưa ra đối tượng hình văn chường,
xin năm 1913 mấy mấy chiến, thuộc chú thịt phố cần thơ, đã hai nhận tận bộ hình vì.
Thật đó, tụi năm 1912 mấy mốt đến khi bị phát hiện,
chân cầu chức ngâm ốc bơ bằng hoa chất với bơ bì mô cờ lớn,
đã sự dụng khoảng năm 1913 sĩ cắt để xử dụng khoảng 3 hình tấn thịt ốc bộ,
sẽ đau đưa ra thì chân tư thuộc trong nguyên năm,
thu lợp bất chính hành tì đời.
Hành vi này thì hiện sự có thường pháp lợp, bất chấp xúc xúc hệ, tính mạng người dân.
Hẹn có quan cạnh rất bộ chạy con 1 thịt phố xin mình,
không cạnh rất kinh tế, đã khu đủ của an,
khu đủ bị càng và bất tạm giâm hình bất chưởng để đủ chá về tổy phẩm,
vuy định về an toàn thực phẩm.